I'm just not gonna work that hard
tonight this time you may have gotten
too close to the edge
can we actually spot some of those
innovative ideas the only time the
success comes before our work is in the
dictionary
working with smart people means that
you'll be challenged to do your best
technology companies live and die by
talent we want them to do the three
things twice as well or do you want to
do twice as many things be an
information fountain are you honest
trajectory for success or on your own
trajectory for failure and we basically
did each of those in a really small
scale she's an American businesswoman
and the president and CEO of Yahoo
previously she was a long time executive
and key spokesperson for Google Forbes
estimates her net worth to be 380
million dollars she's Marissa Mayer and
here her top ten rules for success I'm
how I had a philosophy around balance a
lot of you'll talk about balance I don't
really believe in balance but I do
believe in finding your rhythm and I
think a lot of it has to do not with
three square meals a day time at home at
night eight hours of sleep I think it
has to do with resentment because I
think what fuels burnout is this notion
of well wait I sacrificed this thing and
it honestly meant too much to me and it
meant and it made me resentful and for
me it's really about being able to walk
out of the office for one week every
four to six months find if I I start
pushing that out or delaying vacations
I'll be like you know I'm just not going
to work that hard tonight like I didn't
get to take that trip I really wanted to
take so I think you can work arbitrarily
hard for really long periods of time but
you need to know yourself well enough
that you can avoid resentment and avoid
burnout doing something you aren't ready
to isn't comfortable for me and I assume
for many of you it gives you that uneasy
upset feeling in your stomach that sense
that this time you may have gotten too
close to the edge but I'm pushing
through that discomfort you'll learn a
lot more about yourself
you'll learn to do something you didn't
think you could do or you'll learn where
your limits are either is valuable it's
important to push through that
uneasiness though because in that moment
of finding your courage you really grow
and you really reach I'll say it again
do something you're not ready to do
there's a natural conflict isn't there
in the world of technology between
innovation and execution we see many
companies struggling with it can both be
done well at the same time it's funny
because it was pointed out to me a few
years ago that you know one hypothesis
is that innovation if you think about
what's the opposite of innovation a lot
of people say well it's the status quo
it's stagnancy and you know there's
another school of thought which says
that the opposite of innovation is
execution that if you have to be in
heads-down execution mode is very hard
to find the space to innovate to have
those new ideas and to pull things in
and I know that you know for us at Yahoo
right now there is this is going to be a
great period of execution can we take
these products that we have and
revitalize them for the web and also try
and make the transition to mobile and
while we're doing that execution will
there be room to innovate to say hey
this is how yahoogroups worked on the
web but now there's all these new
opportunities in terms of how group
communication should work on the phone
you know can we actually spot some of
those innovative ideas and I think there
is but it's hard because I do think that
they are natural opposites is size a
barrier to innovation um I don't think
so because I think that it has to if you
you can innovate at scale and with large
size but you have to be very principled
about it you know if you have say 10
engineers and you're going to grow that
to be 20 or 30 do you want to be doing
the same set of things two or three
times better or do you want to be doing
two or three times more things and the
terms of really you know interestingly
in terms of execution this is a great
example of why there's so opposite so
much opposites that if you really wanted
to execute perfectly get the design
exactly right really work through all
the details you didn't ask
two to three times as many people per
project if you want to find those new
ideas those far-flung ideas those things
you might not otherwise find you want to
take those same people and put them on
something that's far-flung that you've
never thought about and so you know it
really is that there is this tension so
I think that you can innovate at scale
but you need to save room to have small
teams working on those far-flung ideas
what's the most important thing that you
do to get it all done hmm
you have to ruthlessly prioritize and I
do and that's one of the reasons I
haven't been talking and I'm gonna go
back to not talking for a while after
tonight because I've been really
internally focused um you know I'm from
Wisconsin and in Wisconsin yeah there's
all kinds of people but the one thing
that's true of all of us is we all
follow the Green Bay Packers to
different degrees and you know it's the
the Green Bay Packers the legacy and the
lore there comes from their first coach
Vince Lombardi who coached them to their
early Super Bowl wins and he's he's
actually quite a pundit like he it turns
out these like kind of phrases you hear
like quitters never win and winners
never quit
that's a Lombardi quote right now the
only time the success comes before work
is in the dictionary
that's a Lombardi quote right um and you
know Vince Lombardi says you know in my
life there are three things god family
in the Green Bay Packers in that order
right and like and you know and I think
that you know for me it's God family and
Yahoo in that order find the smartest
people you can and surround yourself
with them working with smart people
means that you'll be challenged to do
your best you'll have to strive to keep
up with them and as a result they will
elevate your thinking when there are
better players around you you get better
I first noticed this when I was growing
up I had a friend Laura Beckman Laura
tried out for the volleyball team her
junior year of high school and at the
end of the tryouts was given a hard
choice bench on varsity or start on JV
most people in they're faced with this
choice choose to play and we'll pick JV
Laura did the opposite she chose varsity
and she benched the whole season but
then an amazing thing happened
senior year when she tried out she made
varsity as a starter and all the JV
starters from the previous year benched
and I remember asking Laura how did you
know to choose varsity and she said I
just knew I just knew if I got to
practice with the better players every
day I would become a better
player even if I didn't get to play in
the games how does the sporting example
relate to smart people I deeply believe
that the same thing happens
intellectually when you surround
yourself with smart people they
challenge you to think harder and in
entirely different ways what have you
focused on what are you most excited
about when it comes to innovative
technologies particularly the ones do
you have some control over um well I was
really very overall just genuinely
pleased and surprised I knew that there
had to be great people at Yahoo the same
way that when you sometimes look at art
you can tell if it was created by a nice
person or not or a depressed person or
not like when you feel Yahoo's products
you can tell that there's really nice
very smart competent people there that
have a great time and you know and it's
true this is a great company overall
that has a very fun culture and you know
for my first few months my focus really
was on people because I believe
fundamentally that technology companies
live and die by talent and you know
that's why I want to be a people talk
about the talent wars it's not really
that some of the companies that are in
the talent wars are not competitive with
each other it's just that when you start
to see the best people migrating from
one company to the next it means then
that the next wave is starting and so I
got very focused on people building the
right team particularly the executive
layer but all through the business and
also the overall environment and part of
that was because I wanted to make sure
that Yahoo is absolutely the best place
to work and that people really want to
come and work there because that will
help with the talent piece but also
because I believe that really strong
companies all have very strong cultures
and Yahoo is no exception it's been a
very strong company for a very long time
it's got a strong culture it's different
from every other every other corporate
culture each has their own unique and
individual flavor and I really wanted to
find a way to amplify it isn't
amplifying it that's how you find the
energy and the energy is what you can
harness into that innovation and say
okay if we have people and they are
really excited about what they're
working on every day and they realize
that you know the next big hurdle is
mobile you can take that energy around
the culture and find fun ways to apply
it that can be really impact
friend users we like to work with really
small teams yeah when I started there
were about nine engineers I married
answer you said well we have nine
engineers and right now they do about
three different things yeah so if we mm
we have 18 engineers would we want them
to do the three things twice as well or
what do you want to do twice as many
things they said well obviously we'd
wanted twice as many things and and so
yeah that's how we've grown we've tried
to keep the teams really small which
leads to a sense of empowerment people
making decisions around what's the best
feature what are their users need how
are they going to build the best product
and it allows also for them to be really
agile you know we try and avoid meetings
and like a lot of reasons when you have
run the great thing that happens with a
small team is you can put them all in
the same office at Google we usually
have three or four people in each office
and that works really well because when
they wanted to make a decision
people just roll back from their desk
and say turn around what about this yeah
right I got something that we need to
decide right now so that allows the
teams to really be very agile be an
information fountain information used to
be scarce and expensive and power came
through hoarding it and brokering it
today is just the opposite
power comes from sharing information
tell everyone everything the more
valuable the better sharing leads to
connections connections lead to
collaboration collaboration leads to
creativity and innovation creativity and
innovation are what changed the world
lack of sharing can kill innovation in
big companies where division turn
divisions turn into information
fortresses they compete with each other
and end up guarding information from
each other as zealously as they do from
competitors everyone loses as a result
help others find their way by sharing
the information and ideas you have I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about how failure sits in the midle of
startups and entrepreneur I mean what
failure as a fact of life the most
important thing of course is to learn
from failure but I also think that the
other thing that people don't realize
what a failure is it's totally fine as
long as you do it fast right so if you
fail fast and then you're on to the next
thing that's actually successful you're
much better off and
so you've got to be constantly
monitoring your effort figuring out are
you on trajectory for success or on your
um trajectory for failure and viewer on
trajectory for failure decide to fail
fast give it up and move on to the next
thing that can be successful to me 2014
was our time to do a lot of different
experiments we experimented with some
partner content we experimented with
some live content with Live Nation we
had a lot of our editors in different
verticals work on their own series and
clips of what they wanted to work on we
did some original content and we
basically did each of those a really
small scale to understand what worked
well what did we think we produced with
quality whether our audience respond to
and now in 2015 returning to it we're
really looking and saying okay what we
thought work really well was the
magazine content the deep verticals that
Yahoo's always been known for how can we
build out more video there how can we
work out more more on content so when we
do things like the ultimate DJ we're
going to be running an American Idol
like show with Simon Cowell to find the
best DJ in the world next year that
aligns really deeply with Yahoo music
the NFL opportunity aligns really deeply
with Yahoo Sports and so I think that
really helped us shape our content
experience to think about let's run a
bunch of experiments build a bunch of
different prototypes see what works and
what really our users respond to and
that's things like Live Nation and some
of the verticals we've always been
strong in and then how do we build even
more content in that vein thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because home Icaza asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of
Marissa's top 10 rules meant the most to
you and had the biggest impact leave it
in the comments and I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
you
you described a couple of months ago how
one of your employees asked how Yahoo is
going to compete if it doesn't have one
of these four key distribution
technologies there's the mobile
operating system mobile hardware the
browser and social I don't know that we
got an answer yeah I'm also it's funny
because one of our employees at one of
the company meetings asked that and they
said you know given that we don't have
mobile hardware mobile OS a browser or a
social network how are we going to
compete and it's not just the question
yeah clearly it's a question for every
company that seeks to compete with those
others that have those key enabling
technologies sure and you know the of
the Four Horsemen of the internet to
adopt that analogy almost all of them
are playing in one if not several of
those of those media but I think that
the the big piece here is that it really
allows us to partner Yahoo's always been
a very friendly company has always been
because of our key focus also not in
addition to technology but also on media
it ultimately means that there's really
an opportunity for strong partnerships
and that's what we'll be focused on so
we work with for example Apple and
Google in terms of the operating system
in terms of social network we have a
strong partnership with Facebook and so
we're able to work with some of these
players that have a lot of strengths in
order to really bolster our user
experiences that we offer on the Yahoo
site my advice for women is the same as
it is for men which is that you should
find something that you're really
passionate about because passion is a
gender neutralizing force and I really
think that you should work for someone
who believes in you
work for people who believe in you and
invest in you because that's how you'll
go far in your career you're going to
give them a lot of your time be it your
own startup be it a company that you're
joining and you want to make sure that
you also get the responsibility in the
fulfillment that you're looking for and
so those are my two words of advice find
somewhere where you're really passionate
find somewhere where someone believes in
you
my third piece of advice is find
somewhere very comfortable it's
interesting for me because I'm a very
shy person by my nature and and at
Google people don't believe I'm shy at
all because I'm very comfortable there
and that I think is really important
when the most important things for all
entrepreneurs especially for women is to
find your voice and if you can't express
what you're thinking and what you
believe in that's a real issue and so I
think it's really important for for
women entrepreneurs especially to find
somewhere where they're comfortable the
ads and email story is actually a really
embarrassing story for me and in terms
of how I almost blocked a multi-billion
dollar business so it was the early days
of Gmail I was the product manager my
office mate Paul Buchheit was the
technical lead and using what a project
product and you're building it your
specking it but every now and then you
just kinda need to take your mind off of
it and brainstorm further in the future
and so one night Paul and I were in our
office and we always have shared office
at Google sort of three or four of us in
there and Paul was like how are we ever
going to make money from from email and
I was like you know Paul this is simple
everyone's offering four megabytes of
storage we're gonna offer like a
gigabyte of storage and you know we'll
give people some amount of storage like
a gig for free and then we'll charge
them for more more space simple things
like you know I'm not so sure like I
think we should maybe target ads at the
email and I was like you know Paul
that's going to be just creepy so if we
do say this to each other sometimes I
was like people are going to think that
everyone's reading their email and
putting these ads against it that's a
really bad idea and we argued and argued
and argued about it I was like you know
Paul we don't even have an email program
that can send and receive email for more
than the six of us that are using it
right now we have this little program
inside and he was like fine I was like
how will we just figure out like how to
get this working before we you know
really you know go into a lot of detail
about how we're going to make money from
it and you know Paul and I were both
night owls and so around 3:00 in the
morning I went to leave and I remember
walking out the door because Paul would
come in you know probably he was sort of
like this typical engineer they come in
about noon and so I left at 3:00 Paul
was still working away and I remember
walking out the door we had this little
glass pad
all as I watched out I leaned back and I
said so Paul we agreed we're we're not
going to explore that ads idea right now
right and and Paul was like oh yeah yeah
yeah so Paul stayed for another four
hours until 7:00 a.m. when he went home
building stuff and there as I said there
were six lives in the company using the
early form of Gmail and I came back in
like nine in the morning logged into my
email and there were ads everywhere
and so Paul and hooked up the system
that grabbed key words out of your email
and put ads against them and I was like
oh no um Larry and Sergey are going to
show up at like 11:00 they're gonna log
into their email there's gonna be ads
everywhere but I was like no but I could
tell from Paul's emails to me at the end
of the night he'd been working till at
least 7:00 so I was like I don't want to
wake him up now but I'm gonna have to
call him at like 10:30 and be like you
gotta log in and like turn this off and
and so the funny thing was that I had
from like 9:00 until 10:30 to kind of
play with it and Al Gore was coming by
the office and there was an ad for Al
Gore books and one of my friends had
mailed me and said do you want to go for
a hike this weekend and there was an ad
for hiking boots and I was like you know
like these ads aren't bad like they're
you know they're at least relevant if
not useful and you know and so I by
10:30 I decided I wasn't going to call
Paul and Larry answer he came in and
then this interesting thing happened
where and it's sort of interesting in
terms of history cuz people get confused
we were building Gmail and I do think
that whether or not targeting ads that
email is still an open question is still
an open an issue of debate between
Pollan I mean that's how we do it but
what happened that night was Paul
basically figured out how to target our
text ads that have been running
alongside of search at content which
traditionally on the web about 5% of
page views that are done every day our
searches so if you walk into like a
cyber cafe or a classroom about 1 in 20
screens will have a search page up which
basically meant we had a great database
of ads that was good at making money
from 5% of the web what Paul had done
was given any paragraph given any amount
of text
he could find a relevant ad from our
database to run alongside it and so it
basically was a way of taking our ads
database and saying we're not just going
to put these ads on Google search we're
going to put these ads out on the web so
today when you see those blocks of
textual ads that say ads by Google on
the bottom that's something called
Adsense and it was actually born that
night and it in truth is actually much
more successful than even ads inside of
Gmail work is there and Sergey said well
like this is amazing
let's rip this out of Gmail just let
people run this on whatever pages they
have on the web which meant that
bloggers could suddenly quit their job
and blog whole times they could make
money from it and people would really
like about com like we can put even more
content on lines we can make money from
it and so you know we launched Adsense
which I think last year was somewhere in
the you know the 5 to 7 billion dollar
revenue range so you know it was this
really amazing thing where you know that
Gmail that experiment that happened
inside of Gmail became this big product
outside which I almost Quelch with my
you know hey Paul like we agreed we're
not doing that right now I did but you
know that those types of things it's
just you know it's that past your quote
of you know chance favors the prepared
mind of you know you're you're messing
around with these types of things and
seeing potentials and opportunities and
whether or not ads an email is a good
idea thinking about how ads could
targeted email actually let us take ads
and target it really broadly at content